donald trump is the wrong president for
our country
we saw the failure of a government that
tried to deny the virus
then tried to ignore it and then tried
to politicize it
nero fiddled while rome burned
trump golfs under this administration
authoritarianism has taken root
in our country what we get instead is
chaos
division and a total and utter lack
of empathy i don't know about you but i
don't think they like donald trump
he's responsible for covet he's
responsible for its effect on the
economy
he's not just hitler anymore now he's
nero
he's an evil autocrat who eats kittens
probably with ketchup
in short it was just a dramatic reading
of what you've seen on cnn for years
but absolutely no policy yeah minus
measurable facts they offered
unmeasurable opinions
stolen from morning joe's dream diary
take coven
not only did trump shut down travel
early on against the democrat wishes
he also gave each state the ability to
choose a path
so much for inaction and
authoritarianism
he also didn't spread death into rest
homes i think that was a damn
covet is the symptom not the illness
our nation is in crisis and in many ways
covet is just a metaphor you know
maybe sit this one out fella so what
about empathy
well this is coming from a party who
deemed you deplorable
then irredeemable offering a candidate
who said many of you were just
bad people so don't lecture us on
empathy dear dems as you deem us racist
for valuing the police
and let's not forget how many kids your
husband put in cages michelle
and all that droning but at least she
implored us to be better people
you know after one speaker before her
accused trump of murder
but she really nailed trump says the
press as if we didn't see that coming
but notice what we didn't see at all
besides truth
how about the violence innocent people
attacked on the street or dragged out of
cars
beaten double-digit jumps and shootings
and murders
is it because the dems lack empathy sure
the relentless smears against their
inferiors meaning
you has led us to a place where mobs can
brutalize citizens at will
yeah a party preaches empathy while
their very own street team
exacts mob justice with lasers and fists
alas they said nothing about this maybe
because as barack used to say
they built it uh jesse
i was waiting for your commentary on
this because i didn't see you on special
report
uh this was in one way kind of like a
telethon
for trump derangement syndrome like look
what tds has done to their mental state
i don't know greg when the bruce
springsteen music started playing
i started to feel it i was getting ready
to vote for eva longoria and michelle
obama
and then i realized they weren't running
yes so here i'll be objective first this
is my special report analysis
okay the best part about the whole night
was that little video thing they did
with joe biden being the amtrak guy i
think that highlighted his
touch with blue collar people obviously
they portrayed african-americans very
prominently and they really hammered the
covid19 stuff
and they really were focusing on winning
back the rust belt and those obama trump
voters now you want me to say the truth
sure all right here's the truth virtual
conventions are pathetic
it's not the democrats fault it's the
chinese communist fault even though the
democrats won't even tell you that
it was just like a series of badly
delivered
and kind of awkward
state of the union responses yeah poorly
edited together
failed mayors failed governors failed
candidates noticed the two bright spots
weren't politicians and they just
papered over all the violence as the
bodies pile up and
this riot for the last couple months has
cost over a billion of dollars of damage
you know they told lies about cages
mailboxes and ppe
i'm okay with that but here's the thing
joe biden was an afterthought
joe biden the only time he really came
out where they sat him down in a chair
and had him ask other people what to do
that just walks right into the trap that
trump's laid for him
that he has no vision and he's a puppet
which doesn't have a lot going on
upstairs and he did that to himself
and just finally it just didn't have the
feel
of a winning party i think
i think that your point is well taken
the republicans and trump
better learn from this do not do what
they're doing with this
this giant zoom meeting is a catastrophe
katie they avoided every one every
position
whether it be on energy or fracking or
gun control or crime
do you think it's possible that the
democrats realize their positions
are so nuts that they can't tell people
about them
well first of all i heard a rumor that
president trump got the recipe for
kitchen and ketchup from
kim jong-un there you go he sent it one
of those big letters in those envelopes
so that's where he got that from
um but yeah i mean how do you defend um
how do you defend your position on the
police when the party is fighting about
police i mean if joe biden is trying to
say that he's not forward to funding
police but the second he says that like
today
uh there's an eruption inside the left
wing of the democratic party
about how that stance is too moderate
and
he's part of the oppression that they
want to take out and he's part of the
systematic problem
that they claim to be wanting to fight
but you know michelle obama's speech was
great until you started fact checking it
and when you started to look at the
facts of what she was talking about in
terms of going back to
an obama-era style governance on the
economy and a number of other issues
people kind of sit there and say you
know
this is kind of a downer not really sure
what happened to hope with all this
negativity
and second like do we really want to go
backwards instead of forward with
new candidates new ideas and relive
eight years of what we saw with the
obama administration
[Music]
dana the great kyle smith of national
review
said that after last night it looked
like a referendum on trump's personality
is this do you think that's enough or do
you think it's accurate and do you think
that's enough
i think it's well that's it's
interesting because i think that
the first night what the democrats
wanted to do was
to prosecute the case against president
trump from their perspective
okay so yeah so they're going to say
some things that as jesse said like he's
okay with some of the things that they
said because it's politics
and that's what they're going to do so
prosecuting the case against him
includes greg
his personality and his tone and the
lack of empathy as from their
perspective
so i think that that's what they were
trying to do then tonight is where they
try to pivot and now
they're going to try to make the case
for joe biden so then we can get you
know that commentary uh
next i do think that it's good for the
republicans that the
dnc had to go first right in this new
virtual world because they can see like
well we were planning
something like that look like that but i
would also encourage
everybody if you're going to be on zoom
you have to take
just a little bit of effort to make the
shot
look good and that i don't i'm not just
saying if you're going to be on the dnc
convention i'm saying if you're going to
do a conference call with your boss
there are things that you can do you
just google it there's some good tips
on there and you can get a little bit of
a light you got to make it look a little
bit better don't stand so close to the
camera don't be looking down at the
camera
i was a little surprised that they
didn't have more of a better production
value
from that perspective but from the
democrats perspective remember this
convention is for democrats and we can
all look at it and
consider and analyze and things but i
think that
the gloom in doom is matching the mood
of the democrats
and that when you see enthusiasm against
donald trump i think they were trying to
amplify that
yeah i mean it's a fair point juan that
like
you know they're not really running
biden they're running they're basically
running to beat trump it's not like
they're running joe biden they just want
trump out so it would make sense that
they focus
all in on trump but shouldn't they be
shouldn't they've actually said why we
should vote for you too
well i think they did i mean look bernie
sanders gave a pretty good speech in
which he said
he views trump as an authoritarian
someone who wants to delay elections
someone who
says the press is the enemy of the
people someone who wants to
makes baseless claims about voter fraud
and take apart the post office
so i mean at some level you could say
boy i don't want to vote for that
but here's the thing i think you know at
the end of the week at the end of this
convention
what's going to be remembered from last
night michelle obama's speech greg
and why is it going to be remembered i
have two reasons one is
the fact that she said very clearly the
incumbent
donald trump lacks empathy and if you
just look at the way he treated people
who have died john mccain
i can think of john lewis i can think of
john dingle the way he treated those
people in death that's pretty
strong evidence he lacks empathy and
secondly michelle obama said you know
don't think that things can't get worse
don't think that
those authoritarian instincts can't sow
even more chaos and division and
you know alienation the sense of you
know things
in our country are just headed in the
wrong direction that things can get
worse and we need to be aware of that
and deal with it and speak to it and
vote in november
i think i mean to that point it's like
that's what the media has been doing
it's always going to get worse they keep
because things are fine they always have
to say it's going to get worse and that
has actually probably been very
effective
but also i don't know i would rather
have a leader who
lacks empathy and doesn't build body
have body bags come in every week you
know i'd rather have a tweeter
who's a dove then
the virus has a lot of body count well
that had nothing to do with trump
i don't think he created the virus in a
lab i don't think so
i'm talking about americans think that
i'm talking about war what war says
what wars has trump started ability one
question and then we'll go result
wars has uh trump started has he started
any wars
his his lack of ability to deal with
this virus last night
about how in fact her couldn't answer
the question